we had a pedo in Wyoming who came to
drink babies
blood I mean it's so common for people
to be into infants and toddlers three of
them have said they have received child
porn as young as 5 years old on the
scale
of these guys don't consider anything in
the metaphysical realm to these are
interdimensional demons worshiping
Satan where do your marks
fall well um
[Music]
have a seat over there I'm Michael
nolles I'm joined today by the head of
Predator poachers that would be Alex
Rosen Alex thank you for coming on the
show nice meet you you are the new Chris
Hansen yes some may call me that some
may call me that yes so I remember 15
years ago or whenever that show 20 years
ago whenever that show was on Chris
Hansen would come in he'd get some
pedophiles to show up to some house that
he thought was a 10-year-old girl's
house and they'd have all sorts of
disgusting terrible things and then he
would walk out and say why don't you
have a seat Road over there and they'
said I don't know I didn't do nothing I
didn't I wasn't going to do anything
with these handcuffs and guns and stuff
and then they would they would get
arrested your approach is much less on
the nose than that and so as a result
just from the videos that I've seen from
from your
Channel you get a little bit deeper into
the conversation with these
Predators yeah absolutely so it's a
little bit different than Chris Hansen
uh in the way that we go to predator's
houses a lot like just yesterday in
Georgia uh we confronted a person who
was out on bond for child porn charges
and we caught him with child porn again
as he's facing trial already and we just
showed up at his house with no messages
no nothing we just had a phone number
associated with an app that we know to
be child porn related and we talked Ted
to him for like two hours and he
admitted after he got out of jail to
looking at stuff as young as infants and
all of that type again and he hinted at
also trading it again so I think he
could get a very long time in prison
considering that there's going to be two
sets of charges on him in less than a
year but um yeah that's what we do I'd
say we kind of defer more in a way
because we also travel the country
anywhere doing this at this point we
have an arrest in 44 different states uh
convictions in 30 and um there's no
corner of the country we won't go to go
get somebody arrested that's praying
children so what got you into this well
I'm 23 years old now uh I know I look
older but you know seeing you look more
mature right I look more mature thank
you thank you um but you know seeing a
you know Predators genitalia might age
you a little bit and having a BAL Dad
too but um 19 years old I've always
wanted to be a police officer um I
couldn't do that in Houston Texas where
I'm from at 19 you got to be 21 to
graduate the academy at least that's
what it was a couple years ago I don't
know now and um after my first year of
college
I was playing college football um and
well by playing I mean sitting on the
bench but I was on the team so I like to
tell people that I'll tell my kids that
I was just playing and stuff but that's
how I played Little League absolutely
absolutely and um you know I had like a
schedule 5:00 a.m. to 10 p.m. every
night like very disciplined and when we
had summer break like three weeks off
from doing anything I just let let it
all go and I started getting into these
Predator catching videos online um like
anxiety War Justin Payne and Chris
Hansen and I was like well is it really
this many pedophiles around because I
don't know any pedos growing up which is
great but like you know I was like is it
is it really like this bad because I'm
seeing like all these video video after
video like these people have hundreds of
videos to their to their names writing
like this is crazy so I got curious
because I've always wanted to cash a bad
guys I'm like let's see I'm goingon to
give this a try and you know I made a
fake profile of a 15-year-old boy on
grinder and within 30 minutes somebody
wanted to meet up for sex and it didn't
really take long for me to realize that
this is the biggest problem that no one
really talked about was the the profile
just a picture of a young looking boy or
did it say I'm 15 years old um well I
mean it was just a picture of my little
brother like his face and um the profile
didn't say I'm 15 years old but like I
immediately told him I was 15 like I
figured that's how you do it and that
didn't stop really anybody wow so you
did you pursue that sting or did you say
Okay this is weird this is crazy they
want to meet up with a 15-year-old boy
what am I going to do next yeah well I
mean I was very nervous about any
confrontation like at that time like I
was never really nervous like in general
to talk to people but just confronting a
complete stranger who's a pedophile I
was like oh my God how's this going to
go so he met up in a waterburger parking
lot and I brought my friend Jordan to
come and the first bust was just us
getting his license plate and just
saying yeah we got you then just running
back into my car and obviously it's
changed a little bit since that so but
this was the first one this was the very
first one wow so you you've just been
totally committed from the beginning are
you afraid of breaking any laws I don't
know what the laws are in private sting
operations but especially if you have a
liberal da or something I I could see
you know we got a political order now
that always takes the side of the
criminal over the over the good guys so
could you get in trouble um there's
always that possibility but you know at
this point at this point I just tell
myself like we've gotten how many
arrested at this point that we're just
going to go gung-ho with it and whatever
happens happens but we do take a lot of
precautions to not get in trouble like
for example we never let them know
they're being held there like or they're
not being held there but we never tell
them like you cannot we never tell them
like if you do this we're going to call
the cops or if you do this I'm going to
tell your family no type of blackmail or
anything like we just make the
conversation as consensual as possible
and yeah there's not really much people
can say about how we do the interviews
and then as for you know as for chatting
with the Predators like we never uh we
never make them into the Predator like I
tell my decoys I mean at this point they
they're experts on this stuff I think
and chatting with them but I told them
like hey there's no reason for you to
want sex um with the Predator like there
reason for you to say as 11-year-old
girl yeah come over blah blah blah
because you know all these people that
we get online it doesn't really take
much to make them a pedophile they will
just be a pedophile because they are a
pedophile so so the the idea with the
decoys is you just play it straight and
let them let the let the
pedos uh keep moving the ball down the
field yes absolutely yeah that that's
what we do we POS as miners online um
once we think we have enough evidence on
a person that we think they've committed
child sex crimes we go confront them on
camera we hope to get some admissions
out of them usually that seems to work
and we hand that over to law enforcement
so how many stings have you done oh my
gosh um I think close to 600 over the
years whoa are you involved personally
in all of them or is it wow how long
have you been doing this four
years do you ever go to the movies or
something do you ever have a day off
well I don't take off days I I I'll love
to work so luckily I think catching
Predators is the funnest thing somebody
can do so it really works out well for
me that like it's my job but it doesn't
really feel like a job like it's a
really fulfilling thing to do and
knowing the difference we've made in
people's lives both uh families are the
predators kids are the predators their
victims and all of that stuff it really
it's really fulfilling and you know in a
way even for the Predators right because
these are obviously very very sick
people yeah and it it would be bad for
them it's bad for everybody it's but
it's bad for them as well if they commit
these crimes it's bad for their souls
and it's bad eventually when they get
caught and maybe they would have done
something much worse than whatever it is
that you caught them about to try to do
oh absolutely um one of the things we
like to say in the interviews is like
basically give them the given the route
of confessing like oh I would have had
sex with the girl if she was okay with
it you know we're talking about
11-year-old girl here but if they have
the thing of consent in their head
they'll be like oh yeah yeah I'll admit
to that because you know I was going to
do it if she was okay with it but you
know we've we've had stings where we
pose as pedos ourselves like a guy that
a guy I'm about to bring up David Dunn
in Midlothian Virginia um we were posing
as as a fake pedophile online and he
either messaged me or I messaged him
when we know they're pedos we can kind
of just throw like if we're posing as
like another pedo it doesn't really
matter who messages first because we
usually get them on child porn and stuff
like that but he messaged me saying like
hey you know do you want to trade and
obviously we can't trade child porn or
receive any of that because you know
we're private citizens we're not like
some special people or anything but um
you know he was under the impression
that I had a nine-year-old daughter and
that's where my looks are actually a
good thing for one not around woman but
like you know actually a good thing for
once like for pedos because they think
that old yeah they think that I'm mature
enough to have a nine-year-old daughter
and so I actually video calleded this
guy as myself and he was telling me like
oh I'm watching child porn at work and
you could watch this video on Rumble
just type in Predator posters on Rumble
it's there that video is there he's like
oh yeah I'm watching child porn at work
oh yeah he's like oh so you got a
daughter oh I can't wait to be with her
stuff like that
and it just goes to show you they're not
sorry about anything they're so it was
really A New Perspective for me even
because they're so masked off behind the
scenes like these people are sick and
they take pleasure in what they do they
don't regret it so how many of these
people are
just porn addled you know that just
their brains have been melted like
they're watching this at they're
watching extremely illegal material at
work like they want to get caught how
many of them are just that they're so
far down some fantasy in the virtual
realm versus people who have a daughter
and are filming things and producing and
distributing this kind of pornography
well with David Dunn it was kind of both
um he since he doesn't talk to his
daughters anymore which in a reason
we'll get to here in a couple minutes um
he his only Outlet is child porn um so
he we ended up confronting him a few
weeks later he ended up blocking us
because we didn't jump on an app to
trade child porn with him because you
know we Tred to get around it like oh
I'm still I'm real but I I'll trade with
you after we meet you I'm trying to
download the pictures I don't yeah like
we he just wouldn't buy our excuse he
knew it he could smell a sting a mile
away yes absolutely so we confront him
anyway at his home and I tell him like
hey man I was the guy you were talking
to and he's like oh crap and he ends up
confessing to thousands of images of
child porn on his laptop his phone and
the cops sees his devices that day the
next day he got arrested and you know in
that interview he admits to molesting 10
different kids um when he was like
probably around my age like around like
he was like 18 I'm not 18 19 but when he
was around like 18 19 20 in a trailer
park um he said he had sex with like 10
11 year old kids like all around the
trailer park and then he he wouldn't
fully admit to molesting his daughters
but he's like he gave the answer I can't
control what I do in my sleep and then
you know after he gets arrested a few
weeks later his daughter gets in touch
with me and you know she she obviously
told the real story about what happened
with him and it wasn't uh pretty
so wow cuz I guess in my mind with the
Chris Hansen guys like in the old that
old
show I assumed it was just a bunch of
losers like the biggest losers you've
ever seen in your life who I almost felt
bad for them in a way I mean you don't
feel bad because they're going to commit
a crime so you know they show up there
and you think all right well you get
what you get man
but I I gu in that
show you never you never really hear of
them actually doing anything other than
you know sending all these awful
messages to kids
online but what you're uncovering is
people like not just doing online things
which is which is bad enough an actual
crime and actually leads to victims in
the real world but like tangible evil
acts of sexual
exploitation yeah we we like to leave no
doubt in the videos like my coach in
high school always used to say like when
you finish something leave no doubt and
you know when with a video like David
Dunn no it wasn't some lonely guy who
hit up a 15-year-old this was a guy
going after a nine-year-old girl who
admits to all these victims like we we
like to show these people are not just
Los yeah of course they're losers but
they're not just that we like to show
these people are serial child molesters
or seral porn well not just porn addicts
but child porn addicts or serial
pedophiles and you know I think our
videos or at least the intent of them is
to leave no doubt that these people
getting exposed and arrested uh deserve
the rest of their life if not you know
death in pron so what what is the full
profile is there variety among these
guys are there different types is there
just one type is it you say they're all
addicted to porn obviously is it is it
the porn that's the driver are they are
they born this way is it so some
combination well um I don't know if I
don't know how much we agree on what I'm
about to say or not but I think it's
similar to like being gay to where I do
think some people are born gay but I
also think people are molested as kids
and then that gets nurtured but I think
that I think that genetic thing has to
be there so I think it's the same with
pedophilia um everybody that's a
pedophile has to kind of be born that
way because we have people uh survivors
that watch our Channel and the last
thing they would do is touch a kid men
and women alike they're like this is
disg I hate these people like they're
they would never touch a kid yeah but
you know a lot of these people that we
catch have been abused so I think they
have to have that gen in them but maybe
abuse when their kids nurtures that Gene
and there's a lot of people that we get
that just have never been touched as
kids and they're like no nothing
happened to me I had a good family and
I'm just like this like for example the
guy in Georgia we caught yesterday um
but is it the case that many or most of
them were abused as kids themselves like
5050 not the not 5050 is pretty big
though yeah yeah I don't think 50% of
the general population was sexually
abused thank God right so so that's
interesting I actually hadn't considered
that so disproportionately
these are this is a self propounding
compounding problem but I still I I
still think it's genetic though because
say if they're abused by a family member
well I think that I think it just runs
that family that people are like that I
mean we've caught people who and their
relatives reach out to us they're like
that whole side of the family does that
to their kids and it really it really is
a very deep cycle and yeah I think it's
mostly genetic and I think people are
just born effed up now they they
famously have never found the aene right
so I my own musings on the subject are I
guess this is like a non-answer but it
kind of makes you sound smart and
open-minded I just assume there's some
combination for all of these sexual
proclivities and all proclivities for
that matter I assume there's maybe some
predisposition from Early Childhood or
from birth and then some social factors
can happen you know like a guy a
straight guy goes to prison and then you
know all of a sudden he's a gay guy I
don't know that's kind of wouldn't seem
genetic to me true but and it wouldn't
be that he was abused as a kid it was
maybe it's just some other so I guess
I'm just trying to hone in on the
profile of these
guys if they're just born that
way is it hopeless for them and and
likewise if they're born normal and they
have a normal upbringing and it's all
fine could could even a a normal person
fall into this stuff
too well I think you need to be a normal
person falling into it have to be
genetically predisposed to fall into it
so the guy we caught in Georgia
yesterday he's like well I'm in a child
porn because I was I was watching porn
since I was 12 years old and I'm
thinking to myself well I first watched
porn when I was 14 years old and you
know luckily I haven't watched it in
like years but the median age is 11 or
something that's what famous study say
that yeah yeah and like you know in
sixth grade you know some kid had his
phone out he's like oh Alex look at this
and it was like porn but I don't like
11y olds I don't like 14y olds I like
adults so that was a BS excuse I just
think he's born born a pedophile and he
tells that to he tells the porn excuse
to himself to obviously sugarcoat what
it really is but yeah I I just that
could be the case what do I know but I I
fear on the other side sugar coating the
porn and here's why uh
without uh violating any disparagement
or defamation laws or whatever there's
an investigation by sound
investigations um ardan young was the
reporter that was talking to Executives
or or I'm sorry senior staff at PornHub
companies or you know the biggest porn
company in the world and they said that
they insert themes into the straight
pornography in order to convert now they
would probably say they mean this in a
marketing sense you know a customer to a
new kind of customer uh straight guys to
watching porn that they otherwise might
not have looked for
meaning I as a reasonable viewer of this
interview not of the porn but of of the
interview would conclude that they
believe you can change people's porn
preferences and tastes and
things I'm I don't want to defame or
disparage any of those wonderful sweet
senior staff members at porn but it
would seem to me that that would be a
reasonable conclusion from their
words so is it possible that these guys
is that a normal person who just watches
a zillion hours of porn might end up in
one of your
videos or no you say no it's just
genetic yeah like it it can be yeah but
it can be nurtured by that because you
know when I watched porn from like 14 to
17 I it never it never devolved into
like you know regular stuff to like
anything crazy or anything like that
like it was pretty much like the same
thing I would like but I think people
maybe you know maybe it's not a ped
specific May maybe it's just they're
predisposed to social engineering or
maybe they're more apt to be social
engineer than others because you know my
whole thing my whole thing with porn is
like and even like the fent and all
crisis and all that it's like there
would to be a crisis if you just didn't
didn't watch it or didn't consume in
right but you know some people are just
weaker than others when it comes to that
stuff like I'm weaker when it comes to
eating too much like obviously so
everybody has their vices so I don't
know um I've asked people like is there
a certain child porn video you like to
view the most like we had this
firefighter in Ohio that we caught but I
asked him so what's your like do you
have like a favorite video do you have
like a one you like to watch he's like
no I kind of just go on to the next next
thing and I think that's how a lot of
them are it's like they don't they save
the videos but they never really go back
to it it's just always a new thing they
need to get they that's why they call it
a collection I guess W so they save the
the it's not like they go on a uh
streaming service and they say okay they
they save it to their computers which is
how they get pinched for possession of
child pornography right right yeah uh
they they do oftentimes save it and even
if they don't like even if they were to
go to a streaming server they they they
F themselves because that they'll get
caught that way too right well right
there's no way to you can't have
anything on your computer without in in
some sense I don't know I'm not a tech
guy but I assume you have to kind of
download it in order to even look at it
like I have to I have to download a file
if I want to read the file even if it's
right what again I I took like seventh
grade computer but I think I'm speaking
from Authority here I think that's what
that means right yeah well apparently go
back to that guy in Georgia he he said
he had a 26 and this after he got
arrested he had a 26 gigabyte child porn
file that he opened like a couple months
ago as he's out on Bond and he claims
well didn't download I just opened the
file up and looked at it so I don't
really know how that works because I
mean I don't know sounds like he
downloaded it yeah he definitely
downloaded it are these
people extremely stupid is is the
predisposition for them you mentioned
they they're weaker which might be that
they just haven't cultivated habits of
virtue or might be that they just are
are born with a a weaker uh resistance
resistance to these things is it just
because they're
idiots are they
idiots yeah I'd say a lot of them are
but you know I I think it comes from
it's so easy for them to do it because
like I don't think there's more pedos
now than there was 50 years ago at least
percentage of the population wise but I
think they can just offend 247 because
they can you know 50 years ago you
couldn't go online and watch shapour now
you can right but
right he he his first message to our
13-year-old decoy is like I have
pictures naked pictures of girls your
age do you want any obviously we said no
but he's saying that under his name with
his fire department logo on as his
profile so instantly just on that
message alone we could have just
confronted him and been like hey man
what's up so I mean it's insane so what
explains that I guess it could be
explained by extreme stupidity but I
don't know he's a fireman he's like
operating in
society or is it that they just become
convulsed by this Obsession and by this
lust and buy the it just drives them
insane yeah I I think it's like kind of
like that like it's like tunnel vision
because talking to him he's not a he's
not a low IQ guy he's 25 years old he's
a homeowner he has like two acres doing
pretty well for himself um no definitely
not like any type of mental disabilities
like if we if he wasn't a pedo we could
probably shoot the crap about anything
you know he's smart dude but no I I I
don't know what it is I I think you know
the game Sharks and Minnows you play in
the pool yeah like okay there's one
there's one shark and there's many many
minnows and I think that's the way they
look at it there's like what are the
chances I'm going to be caught cuz
everybody you know there's so many of us
and only a few people catching them that
I think it's just that mentality so how
sophisticated does it get you mentioned
guys just banging around the trailer
park you know downloading stuff in this
really seems like a clunky way
yeah when I hear about political stories
involving pedophilia I I'm thinking Rich
guys I'm thinking smart guys I'm
thinking powerful guys I'm thinking
Jeffrey Epstein's Island m is is that
part real you know obviously Epstein
Island was but is or is are the vast
majority of these guys just like dumb
idiots who have no self-control and and
get caught well I think the elites are
definitely real like but the thing is
we're not going to catch we wouldn't
catch them on Instagram or anything like
that so we can only make a difference in
what we can make a difference in like
you know if a ped if a ped's abusing
kids it doesn't matter if they have
billion dollars or if they're on welfare
if they're abusing kids they're abusing
kids so that's the way we look at it but
yeah I think that stuff's definitely
real like we had PTO in Wyoming who came
to drink babies blood like essentially
adrenochrome and people say that just
doesn't happen so I don't
know go on okay so the guy was 19 years
old if you can believe I think the
sickest mind like he he doesn't have the
most victims obviously because only 19
we've caught like 70 year olds but he
but his name is Clayton Tanner I could
say his name because he's convicted
already in prison Clayton Tanner and 19
years old what we found out when we
interviewed him is that he was already
being investigated by Cheyenne Wyoming
Police Department for child pornography
so he came to meet he was texting cuz he
so he didn't have his phone at the time
uh he was texting us from his mom's
phone talking about uh we had an
11-year-old decoy with and we just want
to see how sick he was with a with a
baby sister who's one years old and he's
like I want to I want to cut up he's
like I want to give you guys Cuts with a
knife and drink y'all's blood and you
know he's saying this on his mom's phone
so he walks over from his house to the
park with his mom's phone he's re he's
redown he's redownloaded all of his
child porn on his mom's phone um and I
asked him like said did you bring the
knife and he brought the knife he had
the knife with him uh full intent there
and I he was pretty honest about it to
be surprisingly and he just admitted
like Yeah I wanted to do all this and
yeah did did he explain why he said he
got abused very hard at four years old
so I think that played a factor into it
but it's not an excuse obviously yeah I
guess it is something of an exp
explanation but mhm that one's even did
he say he wanted to have sex with the oh
yeah that that was that that was part of
it the blood was the or derve well it
wasn't just that too it was um it was
blood he wanted to
literally I trying to think he wanted to
literally I think something with I mean
this was in 2022 so my mind's kind of
going blank but like he just was had the
most depraved mind we've ever seen from
anybody you ever read 120 days of Sodom
by the Marquee Dad I've not it's a it's
a book of philosophical pornography I
didn't make it all the way through but
he's a real philosopher it's where you
get the word sadism from sadist you know
is just s and it's
about it's written by a real philosopher
but it starts out with this dinner party
and it gets a little titilating and then
before you know it it's like people are
murdering people and you know it's just
is as depraved as it gets that's the
nearest I've heard to that in real life
life yeah but that guy that guy just put
it on paper and well he probably acted
it out too if he's like that but no
Clayton Tanner yeah no that's uh that
that was his thing and even just a
couple days ago in San Antonio we caught
a guy um and he wanted to give a to what
we said was an autistic 5-year-old so I
mean they have no limit I mean you know
that
is that involves yes right okay yeah
yeah ah
yeah oh man you've stumped me I usually
I in interviews I usually can just kind
of follow the conversation you've
stumped me that is
so disturbing yeah it is it is it really
is like you know because the thing with
Catch a Predator you saw like all right
well the 13 or 14 year old girl they
want to have sex with them it's just
kind of like a a common like little just
stereotypical hookup with like a kid but
I mean it's so common for people be into
infants and toddlers like I would say at
this point I'm trying to think me let me
just think we've done four catches of
strip already so four of them two have
been arrested already and three of them
have said theyve received child porn as
young as 5 years old and only one of
them has not admitted to that so it's
more common than not at this point I
think for our our people we get do you
ever get the guys who produce the porn
or are they or are they to sophisticated
and
protected um I wouldn't say they're
sophisticated and protected um talking
about Cheyenne Wyoming um so we had
Clayton Tanner then the other guy we
caught Cheyenne Wyoming was also one of
our worst his name is Mike schaer he was
texting who he believed to be a nine and
a six-year-old and you can watch all
these videos Predator poachers on Rumble
all you got to do is type in the city so
p r d a t o r space p o a c h e RS then
whatever City so Cheyenne in this case
um completely free to watch so Mike
Schaefer was texting who he thought was
a 9-year-old girl with a six-year-old
sister he wanted to you know do stuff to
both of them and there was really no
like date for the meeting he's like yeah
we'll do it one day and all this type of
stuff but we found out he worked at a
hotel in Cheyenne at the Microtel and
he's convicted at this point too so we
could say his name but you know so we
interview him he admits to trading child
porn and you know doing all that stuff
wanting to do all that but he did not
admit to producing child porn and we
only found out when he got convicted
that he actually victims that he
produced with so I think there's a lot
of producers that we have caught that we
just don't even know about and and take
this guy we caught and I'm not going to
say his name because he hasn't been
arrested yet but he's it's going to come
down on him soon um I just call I'll
just call him K uh so we caught a guy
named K and you know one of my decoys he
messages me like hey uh should we go
after this guy because we don't we we
try to run this guy's phone number to
see if he was in any had any apps that
we know to be child porn related he
didn't have any of those so my decoy
sitting in the audience right now he
messages me saying hey should we message
this guy um and just see like what he's
doing because the case picture on
Facebook was him and his daughter and
his daughter's very young and my decoy
noticed that you know like on the banner
of Facebook like how you can have like a
your profile pick then like your little
Banner whatever so we noticed on the
banner that um the daughter's face had
like some fluid on it right here and it
could have been water could have been
anything but very strange that in like a
ped Related Group on Facebook and that's
his little pick so um so my decoy hits
him up as a pedo saying like hey did you
were you able to join any of these apps
and K's like no no I haven't joined any
of them yet but he invites us over for a
quote unquote play date with his
daughter we're near we're near all these
people they're we'll be there tomorrow
right right and you know so he invites
us over to his little small town and he
invites us over he's like come over on
Sunday I get custody of her she's at her
mom's right now and and you know my
decoy asks him like Hey so what have you
done with her and he's like oh I've
touched her a little bit and uh I've
taken some pictures of her and he's like
we can do we can do all that when you
come over so we go over on Friday not
Sunday because we didn't want to go over
there when she was there obviously yeah
and I knock on his door I'm like hey K
we got to talk about these messages um
just online and he's like oh my God and
you know he's like he's he's like
flabbergasted he's like he's like so
like stressed out about all this and his
excuse to us was oh well uh you know I
was trying to do what you guys are doing
I was trying to catch pedos too and you
know throughout the interview I was like
oh wow man cool cool so I basically I
started asking about his family
schedules I'm like when does your wife
go to work when does your he has a wife
and the ex the ex- baby mama so like
when did she go to work when did she go
to work like basically trying to pin his
schedule to prove that he was inviting
us over when his daughter was with him
alone and he said enough to where I'm
like dude you just told me that
everything lined up to where you were
inviting us over when your daughter was
there alone and I'm like how is that how
does that make any sense that you were
trying to catch pedos if you're inviting
us over when she's alone and you know I
asked him too like did you tell the
police about this he's like well I was
going to I was going to tomorrow and of
course he wasn't going to tell the cops
and then I asked him like um there's
obviously some type of issue going on
and you know he just had a stroke
recently apparently too so I like kind
of let him play into the stroke excuse
as to why he's doing this I'm like
there's something going on man you know
and he's like okay well you know just
the past couple months I've been curious
about this stuff and he's like he just
blurts out I think my daughter's smile
is attractive and I'm like oh okay and
he still wouldn't admit to touching her
or to producing with her he already
admitted to it though but he he was
saying I was just lying yeah he was like
I was just trying to to catch people but
he wouldn't he wouldn't verbalize it on
camera so I was like look man look I I
know there's some pictures taken it's
okay we all get carried away I said
something to the extent of like you can
be a good father and still make mistakes
and he's like no I haven't done I'm like
well can we get get your phone and just
make sure you have and he's like oh yeah
then he was like well can I just go get
it myself and I'm like and I'm like
that's at that point that's when I was
like I've already seen everything that's
on the phone you have a shitty Android
it's not hard to see what's on there and
I haven't actually seen anything on the
phone but they believe that and I
was like we've already seen anything on
the phone then he breaks down he's
like okay it's the phone at my store
that's where it's at and he's like but
I've never touched her though I've never
touched her though and you know but the
foot's the door ready and then I asked
him all right I could go to the
elementary school that uh your
daughter's at right now and I'm either
going to hear it from her I'm going to
hear it from you I'm I told I will go
walk over there right now and go talk to
her then he's like okay okay I've I've
rubbed her I've rubbed her and I've
touched her and then like he starts like
spilling and I'm then I ask him the
question straight up I'm like how many
times have you molested your daughter
and he's like two to three times and he
says it right on camera then we call the
cops and he admits it in front of the
cops and uh right now it's an open
investigation on him and I think it's
going to be our longest sentence when
it's all said and done is this that's
incredible that's incredible word is
this admissible in court yes it is
absolutely because there's no duress at
least we try to make it that way there's
some PDS that are like oh well you're a
bigger guy you were surrounding him but
we try our best to not do that like we
film from the car often to where it's
only me talking to the predator and no
surrounded by anything so they can't say
anything but I believe I told like it's
voluntary to talk to us um you know I
didn't force him to say anything he said
like I just point out inconsistencies
and let him say let him bury himself so
it's absolutely admissible in court like
we've had um our second longest sentence
which is 35 years for a guy named
Jeffrey wager he's currently serving it
out he he didn't uh well he didn't get
convicted yet or maybe he did at this
point for texting our 11-year-old decoy
he got convicted for admitting to us he
molested his stepdaughter so he was dumb
enough to not plead guilty so he went to
trial for it they played our video of
him admitting to molesting a
stepdaughter in court and uh well it's
pretty blatant I mean he got the 35
years so
whoa I don't think if I were in your
shoes I don't think that if I went up to
one of these losers who had downloaded
50 bazillion gigabytes of
pornh I don't think it would I would be
fighting to restrain myself I think i'
just say you're just such
a a sad case and you're doing terrible
things but you have no right what
whatever call the cops you're arrested
but but like one of those guys who says
yeah yeah I've been molesting my
daughter how do you restrain yourself
when this guy says this because you're
you're very even Keel in the videos yeah
well um I knew I mean I knew he was so
full of from the jump when he
started saying those excuses like oh
I've never touched her I was just trying
to catch PE people like you so you know
with that if I if I if I call him sick
and I'm like oh you're a piece of crap
you know you said this anyway how could
you fantasize about your daughter it
would have ended right there he wouldn't
have admitted to it now me getting mad
at him for 10 minutes would have
potentially prevented a 50-year sentence
in prison so uh the ends justify the
means so I think you've already kind of
answered this with your other examples
here one of the knocks always on Chris
Hansen was that they were entrapping
these people that it was that that they
were actually creating the lusts and the
demand
and just by having decoys go on and talk
to these older
men is is that a fear that has gone
through your mind that we're entrapping
them yeah no and not even just
entrapping them but that you are
actually cultivating the lust that
otherwise would not be there without you
and the decoys absolutely not because I
can't think of a I I I can't think of a
one one PTO in the past how however many
years I truly believed it was their
first time talking to a kid only one the
rest of them have all admitted to
talking to other miners before um
they've all either a lot of most of them
have had child porn and that's another
way we avoid entrapment you can't entrap
child porn on someone's phone I mean and
a lot of places like I wouldn't say a
lot but there's definitely been a few
places like for example we caught a guy
named and he was initially charged with
you know the enticement of a minor which
is him texting who he believed to be our
decoy and child porn but he also
admitted to us that he molested his
three-year-old cousin so you know since
Milwaukee basically told us even though
they arrested the guy to like f off and
don't do it there again and we're like
all right so they ended up dropping the
enticement charge and just went with the
child porn because it's so easy it's so
easy to prove in court because then they
have to bring like the civilian
Vigilantes or whatever to testify so you
just say here's the hard drive you know
we got him absolutely and I don't know
if he's been arrested for molesting his
daughter yet but they they said they
were invest ating it so yeah I me how do
you let that go though I mean the child
porn thing is very bad and if you can if
you can get him behind bars for it good
absolutely but if he's you know every
moment you don't move on he's molesting
his daughter or his cousin or some
person that he has access to you know
every moment is is endangering that
kid's life yeah absolutely absolutely I
wish there was more I wish it was a
little bit more frantic with the case in
Iowa currently too but you know it moves
slow I mean with Jeffrey manager it took
him 3 months to arrest him and he wasn't
arrested on the spot so yeah it seems
like with the with the molestation it
moves a little bit slower sadly but they
want because they want to interview the
victims they want every all their ducks
in a row because it's not like they I
mean with the guy in Iowa now they
definitely have proof of it because they
have the pictures but you know with
molestation it's it's still he said she
said and you know I guess they just want
all their ducks in a row with that and
in their defense you want if you're
going to prosecute him you want to get
him absolutely you know so what does law
enforcement think of you do they like
you or do they they not like you for
doing their jobs or starting to do their
jobs the overwhelming majority of law
enforcement loves us so you know
obviously the press release for a PD
isn't going to come out and say hey we
endorse what they're doing and we've had
detectives like say behind the scenes we
appreciate what you do so it's
overwhelming support and you know
because in the end we're all on the same
team here because it takes I mean you're
on the same team too you you're
amplifying a message that exposes child
Predators so it it takes all of us
because there's way too many predators
and not enough people exposing it so
right the I think the sharks minow's
example is is probably a pretty good one
yeah where they just think they can't
get caught but you said something
earlier that was shocking to me you said
there are apps for pedophiles how are
there how how those get in the App Store
well like let me let me take that back a
little bit like it's not apps
specifically designed for pedophile well
just used maybe there's there one app
called I only found out about this
yesterday it was called the app just
apps that other people use for texting
correct correct they use it like they
have like a group text or something
absolutely yeah and I mean but there's
this one now called that we haven't even
hopped on yet because I think that's a
one-way ticket to be sent child born
because it's so encrypted yeah yeah so
but at least we know when one of the
pedos were talking to says Hey hop on
with us we don't but at least we know
for sure they have child porn then so I
guess in a way it makes sense that they
would want to go on these Niche apps if
they're more protected or something but
in another sense that seems like the
dumbest thing would do if you were a
pedophile cuz then it's like hey you
know downloading pedophile. comom you
know to your phone no no I'm innocent
right Officer what are you talking about
yeah it's definitely a double-edged
sword and I've told some detectives
because a lot of detectives we come
across like they don't even know like
what is used for or what you know is
used for because you know there us being
23 kind of helps because we're like
better Tech we're better with technology
than like a 50-year-old detective is but
we tell them like hey this app is just
easy picking
like you can just scream out like it'd
be like in India since you said you're
going to India later be like screaming
hey Bel everybody turns around if you
just scream out like hey ped everybody's
gonna say oh that's me so yeah hey deepo
you know yeah everyone raises their hand
absolutely so I get how you stop the
idiots in the trailer parks how do you
stop weird sex stuff in Beverly Hills
and Washington DC and Epstein Island in
the Caribbean uh just allowing free
speech on Twitter and having Trump in
office that fixes everything no I'm just
kidding but like um you know maybe crap
on my end right now with my abilities we
can't but you know there's no perfect
solution to everything you know we made
a difference in the little girl's life
in Iowa yeah and that can have a chain
reaction now we make a difference
someone else's life so there's only I
mean if if there's a room full of
do you clean none of the or do you
clean as much as you can right and
that's the way I look at it but how do
we stop what's going on in Hollywood and
all of that I think it's going to take
more whistleblowers and more people who
are just like I don't care if I lose my
career over this or potentially get
killed like start naming names and all
that at least outing them that'd be the
first and then after that we'll see I
don't know so how do you if you've
got Elite people involved in the weird
sex stuff underage sex stuff which we
which we know fact because we know about
EP
absolutely how do you ever untie that
knot when obviously the political order
and the police and law enforcement are
therefore involved in it you know uh
dick Durban who's one of the top ranking
Democrats in the Senate he was asked by
a reporter the other day uh Senator
Durban why won't you subpoena the
Jeffrey Epstein flight logs and he said
oh no one's ever asked me to do that now
which is ridiculous Marsha Blackburn
asked him to do it you know on in the US
Senate and he oh no one wants that
that's Fox News crazy right-wing no
nobody nobody wants that and then I
think well I don't know if dick Durban
was on the L Le Express I have no reason
to think he was I know some of his
friends were I we just the Bill Clinton
we know on it
and but then furthermore we know that
according to Alex aasta Trump's former
labor secretary who was us attorney
prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein the first
time Alex aosta famously reportedly said
that Epstein belonged to intelligence we
know that Epstein's business partner The
Madam who procured the girls we know
that her father was mobbed up with
intelligence from most likely three
different countries mad MI6 and MI6
thought that he was connected to KGB I
mean this is all I think this is only a
Wikipedia page you know this isn't crazy
conspiracy theory stuff so we know there
were cameras all over the island and his
various houses I mean it seems like an
intelligence operation
or or at least somehow connected to
intelligence so then okay if the ruling
political class is involved in this good
luck trying to stop stop it or even
discover very much about it oh yeah
absolutely it's going to take every
single person in Congress and the all
the way up to the president well maybe
we can keep Thomas Massie the rest of
them have to go it's going to take all
of them to just leave and be overhauled
in order to I think subpoena this
because it's not just uh you know it's
not just the Democrats it's the
Republicans too like you know my my
thing with Trump is like okay if he's
really an outsider like okay there's a I
think there's a difference between not a
politician vers being an outsider he's
not a politician sure but he's
definitely not an outsider I mean he
donated to Hillary was ball buddy buddy
with her um even said like during his
presidency oh we like to get her locked
up before the election now we don't
really care he said this and you know
that's my issue with him if he really is
about it he should have been screaming
and hollering every day release the
flight logs release the flight logs
release the flight logs and that's kind
of my issue with him among other things
like the V but yeah it's a whole
different other conversation right so
you're you're a man of the right you're
a rightwing very very very far right
yeah are there are there any liberals
involved in the catcha catcha petto
community um Predator catcher wise
there's really nobody who's a leftist
yeah it's kind of funny that yeah right
right I will say though most of the
people we catch I guess are Republican
voters not conservative in practice
because a lot of them are like on
disability and Welfare and all that
stuff but you know we get lot of
comments like on YouTube for I mean on
Rumble for example like oh but look at
you you're catching another right-winger
I'm like okay but who are the person
arresting him is a right winger the
person catching him is a right winger
like the you know so it's right I I I
once heard this described
as pedophile is to Republican accusation
as racist is to Democrat accusation that
basically on the right we go too far in
in smearing everyone as a pedo just like
the lib go smear everyone as a racist
whether it's Justified or not do you
think there's any legitimacy to that
accusation oh
man I don't know because I don't know
because I think like do I think those
Elementary School teachers like this
like these like dumb blue-haired women
teaching 5-year-olds about sex do I
think those women are pedos probably not
yeah but I just think I just think they
think it's just not a bad thing yeah
like I don't think they would have sex
with a 5-year-old student you know but
evil has no limit so you don't know but
but they'll put pornography in the hands
you know as long as it's Illustrated and
published by a major Publishing House
they'll put you know a book that that
shows explicit sexual acts between kids
uh into the hands of young children
right and I think those are more of the
useful idiots because there there
there's basically I there's useful
idiots on both sides and the world needs
useful idiots to exist because you know
without there's if there's leaders
there's going to be useful idiots that's
just the truth but those are the useful
idiots and they TR I think they truly
can't make the connection about sex like
kids looking at porn to like eventual
pedophilia and grooming they I don't
think they make that connection
obviously the people at the top putting
that in the curriculum obviously are
pedophiles and obviously no that's the
case but I just think like with a lot of
with a lot of things the the useful
idiot the henchmen are the ones like
that get all the slack and the people
behind the scenes are the you know I I
try to give even the people at the top I
try to give them Grace or or credit at
least I try to be as charitable as I can
to say maybe it's not that they're
pedophiles maybe it's that they are just
beholden to an ideology that sincerely
believes that uh sex is totally
liberating and we should divorce it from
marriage and little children should have
sex and I mean there were theories going
back to like vilhelm R and and these
these leftists in the 1960s who really
believed it would free children it they
would claim it would cure War poverty
disease and so you think look that's
completely nuts it's wrong it's evil
actually but they know not what they do
that's what I try that's what I try to
tell myself and then I see someone like
Orin McIntyre over at the blaze who says
just let's tap the sign it's not that
complicated they just want to diddle
kids one of his most famous lines
probably maybe there's something to that
I don't know no I I I think so because
it's TR truly what what I figured out
doing this I said a couple minutes ago
is like evil has No Limits so we've
thought with we thought with some pedos
like yeah they did this but I don't
think they do this then we find out when
they get arrested oh they did do this
too right and you know I think I
wouldn't give these people at the top
credits like you know the libs that
are the ones teaching the kids the ones
like at the top don't give them credit
to think they're just ignorant too they
know exactly what they're doing George
Soros knows exactly what he's doing
these people I mean evil just exists you
know Hitler and Stalin weren't the only
evil people to exist in the world like
you know everybody points to them they
weren't the only evil to exist evil
exists right here in our country too and
I think a lot of people don't really
because our lives have been so good I
mean in the end like no matter if
Biden's in office if Trump's in office
in the end we still go home to our video
games and our porn and so nobody
really cares but what a great life
exactly exactly but at least people
think it's a great life 100% so people
don't care enough about the evil that
truly does exist here because all they
all they hear about is oh evil was like
in Germany and stuff evil was like here
but it wasn't ever here and it is so
right
so getting back to something that we
talked about
earlier what do you do with these these
pedos who are either hardened by Decades
of porn or whatever you know formed them
or they're uh they were abused
themselves or they're born that way
let's say I don't know any
situation is there any path to
Redemption for these
people yeah um the the guy yesterday
the guy the guy yesterday um I think he
truly needed help and cuz he's just too
addicted to his phone with a child porn
so what I did to get him help I called
this help number um let me Tred to
remember the number the three numbers it
was 911 okay and if he was in prison
he'd have no phone to watch child porn
so I got I was I was trying to get him
that help yesterday then the detective
came and take all took all his devices
so he's already in step one of our
little help program that's that's good
but no
in all seriousness in all seriousness
these people there's no helping these
people they're born that way do you
think if you had okay you love your wife
right so if you had therapy to not love
her would or to not love her and not
want to um you know not find her
attractive do you think that therapy
would work no not in the case of my wife
she's a unique case as just the smoking
hottest little Ellies in the world that
I've been in love with for now the
majority of my life however however if
it were some lesser woman woman than
than my sweet little
Alisa I don't know if it were just some
girl I dated right and then I were
conditioned through therapy MH to be
told all these terrible things about her
or to point out all her flaws or
something like that I could I could
probably have a weakened attraction to
her I'm trying to use the analogy here
like yeah you're telling me there's
nothing I I just it it pains me to to
think this because as a Christian I have
to believe that Redemption is available
to all people and so I'm not you know I
like the self-help number that you
called for the for these guys and I
think simple yeah very simple to
remember even but and and even going
back to like Plato in the gorgius he
points out Socrates points out in this
great work of philosophy that it is
worse to do harm than to be harmed it's
it's it's worse because it it
uh you can't control being harmed
suffering is a fact of the world there's
nothing particularly moral or immoral
about that but if I do evil I'm
compromising my own soul so you know I
mean you're joking about it but you
actually are helping these men by by
doing this to for them but therefore is
it not the case that they will get some
help in prison and they will not have
their phones and their perhaps their
addiction to this stuff will be
mitigated or or no you're shaking your
head zero zero I'm telling you man zero
cuz we caught a guy in in Las Vegas in
of this year he he served 18 years in
prison from like let's just say 2000 to
2018 my ears are a little bit off here
but just paraphrasing yeah um for child
molestation multiple victims he somehow
scored himself a retrial so he was out
on parole um we caught him April we had
a retrial coming up in June um he could
have been a free man right now if he
would control himself but so when we
caught him he was texting who he thought
was a nine-year-old girl um we caught
him he admitted to 50,000 images of
child pornography and this is as he was
wearing his ankle monitor about to have
trial in 2 months to potentially get
everything you saying he admitted to
having had all that child pornography or
he had it even on currently currently
and his excuse was it was a really funny
excuse it was adorable how do how did he
have enough time to get that much porn
that's what I'm saying I don't know he's
like he's like this is how he was he was
like it just comes at me every day man
it's like and like I'm like well how
many do you have he's like oh 50,000 and
his excuse was he's collecting them to
give to the FBI and he's like I have
folders in my room that say FBI on them
there wasn't no folders like that I
wouldn't expect them yeah I was like
well are you at least like saving them
uh into categories so you can give them
he's like yeah I'm saving all of them
and I'm like all right all right like
but yeah there so because of that
obviously you know that uh because of
that obviously the whole retrial thing
didn't happen and he's back in prison
for the rest of his life and see that's
the thing they can't even not look at
child porn for a couple years to
potentially get the worst heinous crime
dropped forever and we there's another
guy in oron uh he he got a threeyear
sentence just think how long that is in
Oregon that's how you know he's Oregon
you could murder a man they you know you
they take you out to lunch at the prison
and then you're out by dinner oh
absolutely absolutely so he was a sex
offender he messaging who he thought was
an eight-year-old girl we caught him in
2021 if you just look up Predator
posters Eugene Eugene organ on Rumble
you'll see that catch there um he he was
a sex offender he just spilled all the
beans like he was one of the most honest
Predators we caught and looking back on
it it's probably because he liked to
talk about what he did to his kid kids
and his cousins and all that but he
spilled everything and then he uh and he
was telling me like yeah well I I take
sex offender counseling and I'm the head
of my class like he's the one that helps
other sex offenders not do it and he's
caught talking to an eighty old
girl oh can they be helpful ever then
okay so you're you're
saying that that actually the self-help
plan for them is life in prison Absolut
there's no that maybe they can you know
accept God's grace work on their soul
and but they they can never be granted
any degree of political freedom because
they're they're just not capable of it
okay correct okay can they be helpful to
law enforcement you know ratting on the
weird apps or the group chats or
anything like that yeah like I've never
been in a child porn group I've never
opened up a I've never been in a child
porn group I've never traded child porn
like I haven't seen any of this crap but
I I have so much knowledge of it because
of interviews with pedos because thing
that I like to tell him is like look man
I care about the produc because that's
how the guy spilled yesterday because he
you know he was claiming he didn't have
how he's like keeping himself
accountable it's all but you
know I'm like hey man well I care about
the producers you know because you're
just a guy you have vices and you have
demons you're fighting but these guys
are actually evil then he's like okay
well this is what they're sending in the
chats boom boom boom boom boom wow and
you know so I I know a lot about this
stuff just from what pedos have told me
so yes they can be very helpful and I
think you know if law enforcement uh
doesn't already utilize them to give
info on other people they definitely
should I I though I wonder what the
incentive would be for them because you
you're saying if you let them out of
prison they're just going to reoffend
you know almost every time so I don't
know what they get an extra helping of
dessert or something yeah I think that'd
be good I think I think that'd probably
be the best thing yeah right why not so
what's the future of Predator poachers
well uh I have I have zero goals all I
know is we just move forward like I like
to say a beautiful picture is painted
with a little small stroke so you know
every day is a stroke right so no I mean
the way I look at it like obviously want
to keep growing Predator poachers and um
you want to keep growing Predator
poachers we want to be a bigger
influence and I think you're helping a
lot with that so I really appreciate it
are you concerned that it personally
will take a toll that you just being
around even if you're saying look I'm
not I don't have to look at the images I
don't need to but you're still hearing
the accounts you're still seeing the
chat logs which are sick you post them
sometimes to Twitter and you know X and
they're even just reading that stuff you
just think you know the eyes are the
window to the soul I don't I don't need
this man do you ever you ever get burnt
out no like this is the funnest thing in
the world to me and yeah I I don't know
like the thing that's been taking a toll
is like traveling the country half the
month in a car like since doing this in
2019 I've gained like 70 PBS that's not
out of stress it's just out of sitting
down a lot and eating a lot of great by
the way but you know but no me mentally
mentally no because you know all I look
at is it's just adversity and everybody
has adversity but I'd rather much be
doing this than like a ninet to-5 so it
is what it is what about the police
academy oh when I settle down with my
girlfriend and she moves in and we have
kids yeah probably so but not not before
then what what does your girlfriend
think about your line of work well I met
her because she was watching the channel
so she likes it really wow that's good
that's good to have a good to have a
spouse on board absolutely what you're
doing is there anything that surprised
you when you got into it obviously you
had been watching this kind of content
that you were now producing and you know
you were eager to catch the bad guys did
did you know what you were signing up
for or was there something that you
didn't expect I did not know what I was
signing up for like I did not like I
didn't start doing this with the
intention of like oh I want this many
Subs on YouTube or I want to make this a
job I literally was like all right what
the hell this should be interesting and
so no there there was literally just no
it was just on a whim and I I think and
I blame my parents for that in a good
way because growing up they you know
they weren't strict at all I mean they
they weren't absent but they weren't
strict like they were just very like L
fair with like okay just be home by this
time and you know go go organize a
football game or whatever so they gave
me a lot of freedom to just think
outside the box and it just be like um
what's the word for it uh not unique but
I don't know just think outside
basically think outside the box as in
like just you know not do everything by
the book don't have to like you have to
do this at this time so you know I I
think the whole idea of Predator
poachers was just the fact that they've
ingrained me from a young age like hey
if you want to go do it just go do it
just don't be an idiot and so definitely
that but what was the question again I
got if you were surprised by anything oh
yeah yeah yeah so what I'm surprised by
is like we started posing as like 15 we
started posing as 15y old old and I was
at 19 years old I was shocked that
anybody would be going after a
15-year-old because even me at 19 I was
like well I would have go near a
15-year-old that's like weird because
you know I remember in eighth grade you
know we had a we had a uh we had a kid
on the football team and he was dating a
sixth grader and we all looked at him as
like ah you know like we look at like
that that's a two-year age difference so
those two those two years matter a lot
you know they matter less over time but
you know you're talking about a sixth
grader is like 11 years old yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's definitely more more so
middle school that's weird then like now
my girlfriend's two years older than me
and I always joke with her like I'm
going to go catch a pedo when I confront
you so what I see you so like but um but
yeah no so what I'm surprised by is like
obviously at first it was like holy cow
people actually like kids and then we
would POS like 13 years old 12 years old
like no way somebody would go after a 13
or a 12y old and then it's then it
became like people like infants and
toddlers and that was like I was like no
freaking way like in 2022 we caught our
first guy and I was like no no this
guy's like the worst bro and now it's
like every other guy's into infant that
we can
so is that H man is that new it's
probably not new I'm sure there have
been weirdos for all of history but but
like I I guess I'm just wondering is is
the problem getting worse are the crimes
getting more violent are the victims
getting younger or or no is this just
the way it's always been well so I think
the same amount of I think the same
percentage of the population of pedos
exist a back then as now but the
internet gives them a 24-hour window to
offend which think about any other crime
like if I wanted to go rob a bank I
couldn't do it 24 hours a day I'd have
to like plan it for a couple months and
all that stuff not giving any tips or
anything I wouldn't know how to do it
but like I plan it for a couple months
and all that stuff but with pet with
with these pedos two clicks and they're
offending so then isn't it
it would seem to me and this sometimes
irks the uh small government types now
look I like a limited government but I
don't want it to be small I don't think
you can have a small government in a
country of 330 million people I want I
want the government to arrest the bad
guys that's a that's a bigger government
that does
that if the thing that is leading these
guys who might have sick fantasies but
now they're acting them out with images
alone and they are now they're texting
people and now they're going to to visit
what if we put limits on how the
internet can be used on they tried to do
this in the 90s the communications
decency Act and the child online
protection act if we put limits on
pornography companies if we put limits
on some of these apps that are being
used for child pornography We There are
insane limits being put on on like
Twitter right by corporations but yet
we're not seeing limits being imposed on
apps being used by pedophiles wouldn't
that be good for everybody and
especially good for the pedos themselves
so they don't have 24 hours a day to
commit their crimes yeah I I agree like
like people say like oh should be banned
from the App Store banned General I
don't agree with that because I think
freedom freedom and god-given rights
over everything to me however I don't
see how being able to message who you
want
on has to involve like child pornography
like there has there there could be
censors for that I think on
that's obviously not Freedom like in the
sense that this guy gets out on parole
and then he instantly downloads 50,000
child pornography images he's not a free
man he our law might have classified him
as free or somewhat free but if you
don't have any control over yourself if
you're being enticed even by all sorts
of Technologies and and other creeps on
the internet you're not free that is not
Freedom actually you more limitations
would give you more freedom in that case
I see I I see what you're saying I see
what you're saying for sure like I still
think it just falls on the individual
but I do think that you know it takes it
takes two like I think it's 90% the
individual's fault and 10% fault but
yeah they need they there are ways I
mean if the FBI can ding images like
because that that's how it works they
ding basically there's certain child
porn videos and pictures that flow
around like very commonly so the FBI has
those videos marked and I think and
these other apps they can stop the child
porn problem without having to
compromise people's ability to text
somebody hey let's go over here hey
what's up hey let's text here because I
don't want you know people seeing my me
text messages yeah what's wrong with
that I I don't I'm as skeptical of the
FBI in the Deep stateus anybody yeah I'm
all for True Freedom why can't they
just do whatever the FBI is doing with
this image and they see the image pop up
and they may maybe even they report the
guy at the very least they don't let it
go around the app yeah I I think I I
think yeah I think reporting them would
be good too if anything they can easily
do that they can easily do that send it
on over to the FBI and let them handle
it letbe send them over to you yeah well
shoot I mean doesn't even respond to
subpoenas though so I mean as as for the
feds doing it like we've we've had feds
take up a lot of our cases um not most
of them but a lot of them and I mean the
Feds that work at the sex crime they
seem to be like very passionate about
what they do and it's not political for
them so very often in these
conversations no matter the topic some
have been explicitly religious I some
have not been really religious at all
but a spiritual Dimension sometimes
Creeps in and I imagine when we're
talking about pretty much the most evil
thing you can imagine there is a
spiritual element here as
well on the scale
of these guys don't consider anything in
the metaphysical realm to these are
interdimensional demons worshiping
Satan where do your Mark
fall well um for example the guy Georgia
yesterday his dad's a pastor he
identified as a Christian um then we've
also had people who are just atheists or
pagans like we had a guy in Florida
recently um he was he's like I'm a pagan
so I was like is that this he was
wearing a pentagram when we caught him
and I'm like well is that like Devil
worshiping he's like no no it's just
you're one with the earth and the wind
and the trees I'm like I'm just think
it's so devil worshiping tomato tomato
yeah right right so no it's it's really
an array of things um we've absolutely
caught our fair share of religious guys
but we've also caught our fair share of
just people who who don't do any of that
religion stuff they they just I mean
they just worship themselves pretty much
they just worship child porn so they
they just create an idol out of that
yeah absolutely well even the the word
fetish goes around you know the origin
of the word fetish is that it refers to
uh an a religious taboo like an object
of religious worship in not in True
Religion but in a like a pagan cult type
thing
so it would seem to me not surprising
that these guys who are willing to risk
their ability to evade jail so they can
download some more glittering images
would get into a little idolatry I think
I forget where I read this years ago
that may was in the American mind that
porn is obviously a type of liturgy it's
a type of uh religious ritual I think so
I agree with you to even even wow how
degraded do you have to
be even just to spend your time doing
that I know I know you don't get all
that much time you're going to die at
some point you know you have a limited
amount of time on Earth you say that's
how I'm going to spend my time that is
so my friend Drew claven has a line he
says sin would be really really funny if
not for all the suffering and that it's
I I
I don't want to laugh at it because it's
it it speaks to something that's very
sick that is so funny that is such a
funny thing that they do yeah yeah minus
all the suffering absolutely yeah no
it's it's unbelievable how a a
50-year-old man yeah when you think
about it a 50-year-old man is talking to
a fake 11-year-old girl controlled by a
25-year-old woman and you know some fat
23 yearold guy and to that to the idea
that it's all real it it's yeah it's
it's it's unbelievable like we like we
think like we always say to ourselves
too like we're driving to a ped's house
we sometimes ask like what what do you
think he's doing right now he has no
idea we're we're on a 15-hour drive to
like South Dakota right now about to go
get him
and yeah they just have they just I
don't know it's it's all
absurd guess I guess that's what it's
all about though you mentioned this guy
who's wearing a satanic symbol say no
I'm not a Satanist no no I'm no no I'm
not I just I'm one with the Earth man or
no I'm just looking at porn or I'm just
you should be one with the Earth under
buried under but like might he might
soon be one can wish
but like they I guess that's one of the
marks of of the devil is not just the
spooky you know evil stuff and rotting
eggs or something but that it's so
grotesque it's so there's something so
just out of proportion and shape I don't
know that what you what you've just
described with the cell phone screen is
is
uh that might be the weirdest thing
you've told me all day yeah yeah CU
because it's just weird in any context
whether it's a pedo or like you know
anybody like some hot hot woman like
it's just disgusting on that disgusting
note now there's one more question I
have to ask you before Before I Let You
Go we've talked about all the guys
you've caught yeah you've gotten and
they go to jail and they you find out
they've committed way more crimes how
many people get
away so um
let me just use an example so this trip
um I'll just use an example this trip um
so far we're in the middle of one so
after we after we bolt out of here we're
going to go to up to Evansville Indiana
and hopefully get two people near
there so this this trip so far two have
been arrested um the guy in Georgia was
not arrested yesterday but the guy in
Florida and the guy in uh Louisiana were
arrested the first guy in San Antonio
who's giv the to to to or wanted to give
to a 5-year-old the cops arrest him well
I didn't sorry they didn't arrest him
they detained him took him to the
station detectives interviewed us um
everybody was on board with wanting the
Predator arrested and then the Da comes
absolutely
not was one of these Soros da type
things yes and then also in Las Vegas
like we had arrested in Las Vegas um but
you know even a Soros da can't say
50,000 child point is like you know the
first 49 get a pass right right yeah
there there was a limit on that for sure
but we had another guy in Las Vegas
recently um he admitted to receiving all
this child porn to talking to countless
12-year-old girls that we were not
controlling and stuff and I mean I'm
sure very rarely do they admit to
molesting real kids but you know we can
get like talking to other miners a child
por out of them but he admits all this
and the cop comes um he's like you know
he's he's like he's just he comes he
pulls me aside he's like Alex I'm really
sorry I was on the phone with the
prosecutor and they said absolutely the
not and you know and you know he hangs
up he's like we're working on this stuff
with he's like he's what's the argument
why not they're overloaded with they
don't have time or I don't know I don't
know or they don't want I guess because
we were civilians it's really weird so
we run into that a lot in big cities but
I'd say in small towns like in small
towns we absolutely get way more
arrested than we don't get arrested so
is that is that a risk though that that
your work could compromise work that law
enforcement's already doing or no is
that it's just an excuse from law
enforcement no because out of the
hundreds we've done I think only 10 have
been investig were currently being
investigated by law enforcement so even
this guy who's out on bond you can watch
his video just type in Predator poachers
Converse like the Converse shoes on
Rumble you'll find it um he was out on
bond for child pornography um we didn't
catch him just you know feds did or
whatever he's out on B for child
pornography he hits up our 14-year-old
male decoy and you know so we go to his
house we could front about the messages
and he admits to having infant
pornography on his phone and you know he
he gets caught up and arrested again so
yeah no so even when law enforcement is
already on them it typically just adds
more to their to their rap sheet
wow so I would be remiss if I didn't ask
how do parents protect their
kids well I mean I was protected as a
kid because I was a I was an ugly fat
little chubster so like not many people
were after seventh grade Alex but in all
seriousness I mean I think first of all
there's no perfect solution to to
everything there's always a risk with
everything but I still don't think be
paranoid because that's letting them win
but I think I truly think the best way
is hand hand your sons a football or
basketball or a baseball if they're into
that stuff you know I you whatever but
or just put your put your girl in
theater class or whatever but you know
it's it's the same thing thing like we
of course blame we of course blame the
robbers and the rapist for crimes they
commit but if your Gates unlock to your
house and your doors open yeah it's
still the robbers fault they shouldn't
be doing it but like you know you could
also lock the door so I I think just
hand hand your kids a football or
basketball I didn't get my first phone
or Playstation first smartphone or
Playstation I was in eighth grade like
hand hand your kids make your kids go
play sports two birds one stone kids are
sitting down too much anyway go go have
them run or something right I seriously
think that it does seem to me that if
you today even if it were different in
the past before technology was so
Advanced if you give your kid a
smartphone today without really period
but certainly without any kind of limits
on it you're just handing them a portal
to hell yes I just I can't even imagine
easy for me to say because my kids are
are still young but as far as I'm
concerned I don't want my kid to get his
first phone until he's like 36 you know
like I don't maybe maybe 18 we can start
talking yeah yeah uh because you know
it's not like occasionally I would
borrow my mother's phone when I was in U
eth grade or early high school but but I
didn't you know that was like I could
play Snake or Tetris maybe if I was
lucky on you know this wasn't like like
you get pedos just beaming in from outer
space just trying to with cameras on the
phone you know it's just completely a
different world yeah oh I mean like even
even me like in seventh grade you know I
joke that no pedos would want whatever
like I was in a group chat on kick in
seventh grade what I thought was like
seventh grade girl hit me up saying oh
show me your and I'm like oh oh what
what but looking back on it's probably
an adult guy asking for that so I mean
yeah so I mean it's that common but
again I wasn't on technology much as a
kid like I was always outside playing
sports and having the time of my life a
good good bit of advice to end on Alex
this was deeply unpleasant yes you you
are not deeply unpleasant you you are
very pleasant and have done some great
work uh I don't want to have to think
about this right for the you will be
thinking about it because it's your job
but uh best of luck in your endeavors
and uh hope you NAB all sorts of
terrible bad guys best of luck to you
too Alex thank you very much thank you
so much thank you we'll see you next
time